so just to
kind of ground this
diversity would be when you have a lot
of
different races ethnicities genders
ability statuses at the table
inclusion is when each person feels
comfortable talking they feel welcome
and and one of the best ways to be
inclusive is to not be exclusive
i think that's
fairly obvious and yet it's completely
missed where there's kind of like this
very exclusionary behavior that happens
you know we don't want this person in
the meeting because we don't find them
helpful which is a function of already
biases or because we find them annoying
or aggressive or combative which is also
a function of various biases
and there tends to be this
this push towards being exclusionary and
in a bunch of ways where we can create
more inclusive spaces as soon as we
realize that
to be inclusive you have to not be
exclusive and so what that means
you know very concretely is if you are
creating a meeting and a bunch of people
pay attention to the demographic makeup
of the people you're inviting if your
meeting is all male
it's a problem
but you'll find
you know in tech a lot of meetings are
all male and if you bring it up
that can be met with a lot of hostility
so i think it's about understanding that
there are strategies here
literally looking through thinking
through the demographics and making sure
that
each associated woman each associated
black person
you know latin next person
that is relevant to the project is also
included i like to say air on the side
of including people
especially when it comes to marginalized
characteristics it's much better to have
someone
who
who might not be as relevant
than to exclude someone who is relevant
so erring on the side of inclusion
when i was first trying to sort of train
my head to be less biased i mean we're
all
we're all biased in our own ways we all
were raised with cultural norms that
really affect how we perceive things
and so part of how i've tried to break
those patterns
is like i spent a good year probably
whenever i wrote an email i would look
at everyone who was in the two and in
the cc
and i would go through in my head their
genders and ethnicities and things like
that
and if i noticed that we were
that it was
sort of non-representative
of all the people working on the problem
i would fix that but it took like
concretely thinking about what are the
important characteristics that tend to
be marginalized
and then now i am going to unmarginalize
them
or unmarginalize the people with those
characteristics
so it's a very conscious effort
and that's something that
you know i guess depending on the
culture that people have been brought up
in they're more or less
um
interested in in doing
i think in the us
there has been a good response to that
kind of approach
i'm less sure
in in france which is like also very you
know where hugging face is how much
that's appreciated
but at least at least in the us like
that kind of very intentional thinking
through demographics
helps and and people are generally
responsive to that as long as you tell
them beforehand if you if you catch them
in the moments um like only preferring
majority characteristics like people get
very mad and defensive yeah
so you know as long as you mention it
beforehand that it's usually a lot
better
that's a really great thing to be aware
of i'm curious to you know
i feel most of us at hugging base are
pretty
data centric and data aware and
i just i can't help but wonder and think
about isn't there proof
how inclusivity and diverse
individuals working on the singular
project produce
more successful outcomes yeah yeah since
you have i mean minimally since you have
different perspectives you have a dis a
different distribution over options and
you have more options
and so you know one of the fundamental
things about machine learning is like
how you should start training whether
you want to use some you know randomized
starting point
and what kind of distribution you want
to sample from
and
most people agree that you don't want a
sample from this one little piece of the
distribution in order to have
the best chances at finding like
like a you know an optimum like a local
optim
so
that's understood in machine learning uh
so it's just sort of you need to
translate that to the people at the
table like just how you want to have
this like gaussian sort of
approach distribution over different
kinds of start states so too do you want
that at the table when you're starting
projects because it gives you this
larger search space and makes it much
easier to get to some sort of local
optimum
absolutely i've never heard it explained
like that i think that's brilliant
yeah i think it's i think it's maybe
something that resonates with machine
learning people a little bit
a little bit more easily than saying
like you want different perspectives
oh my gosh i love that so much
you